alors je rappelle un demi pied des
spectateurs qui sont pas obligatoirement
au courant qu'en 2006 devait faire un
groupe qui s'appelait de jean d'ormesson
disco suicide aqps tu en voilà et que
vous avez sur l'épaule un tatouage de
jean d'ormesson voila voila j'ai eu gens
dorment suns tatoué sur le saumon pollue
golly chasse enlèvera jamais il ya de
fortes chances que je garde ça toute ma
vie alors vous lui direz en fait que
tout ça c'est une vaste blague vous
foutez de la gueule depuis le début mais
non pas du tout c'est
pourquoi sa non métier bien défoncé
camborde pour un groupe en 2010 que
celui ci soit quand même hein le groupe
était est et était dans un moment de
doute et justement c'était quelque chose
de plus mystique que piquet je pense
nous est femme de jean d'ormesson
jeu en fait le gros je n'ai jamais lu de
livre de jean d'ormesson et voilà l idée
c'était c'était que moi j'ai jeu j'ai
apprécié sa manière justement d'aller
faire la promo en télévision sa manière
de s'exprimer sur son travail jean
d'ormesson sera avec nous il nous
parlera de son dernier livre qu'ai-je
donc fait chez robert laffont voilà
jean d'ô il est fan de vous est ce que
vous êtes fan de lui j'aime beaucoup
mais julien sauf qu'il a réussi à ne pas
se laisser écraser parce qu'il a eu du
succès de conciliables et serait très
compliqué passé s'est écrasé je suis
enchanté de voir qu'ils continuent
brillamment
le cas méfiez vous quand même le jean
d'ormesson parce qu'il serait capable de
vous chopez louise
si je pouvais
c'est vrais gens on raconte que en fait
le viagra et bleu parce que c'est un
hommage à vos yeux c'est vrai
vous intéresser aux femmes depuis très
longtemps depuis soixante dix ans au
moins vous avez connu la ceinture de
chasteté genre
moi je vais vous dire un truc gens tout
simplement quand on vous voit ça donne
envie d'être vieux
c'est vraiment
c'est un bonheur c'est un bonheur il y
en a plus des gens comme vous
bon alors genre vous publié chez robert
laffont qu'est ce donc fait alors par
jean d'ormesson de l'académie française
vous êtes immortel à deux titres d'abord
parce que vous êtes à l'académie
française et ensuite parce que votre nom
est tatoué sur l'épaule de julien doré
donc votre nom survivra
inéluctablement je vais vous dire je
serais plutôt confiance à l'épaule de
tenue
et je servais la définition des
accueilli siens par jules renard que
j'aime beaucoup le commun des immortels
bien c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
les coachs en nordic partir en vacances
avec lui parce que toute la journée
comme ça il doit raconter des histoires
c'est formidable alors bon les thèmes
habituels de d'ormesson évidemment la
vie la mort les femmes la littérature
est toujours cette interrogation
taraudante que vais-je laisser que
vais-je faire avant de mourir vous savez
c'est d'abord un écrivain doit faire
attention à tout ce qu'il écrit il doit
faire attention à tout ce qui dit et il
doit faire attention à la façon dont tu
meurs vous savez c'est très mauvais pour
un écrivain de mourir par exemple en
même temps que cash oui mais c'est ce
qui est arrivé à cocteau n'y a pas pris
toute la lumière pour elle par les bouts
de cocteau il ya un autre écrivain à qui
j'ai succédé à l'académie qui est jules
romain jules romains aimant le 14 ou ses
désastreuses mourut un peu trop faire
attention à ce que l'on a
caen joue tout le monde s'en foutait
absolument alors vous plaignez beaucoup
quand même ne pas être montaigne ou
chateaubriand et vous êtes finalement
que le monsieur du figaro et ça vous
désespère ça
et encore les gens savent pas que votre
vraiment c'est jean lefebvre
au grf temps je vais bien je lui
répétais souvent tous les vivres
voilà alors en fait le problème nous dit
j'étais trop peureux pour être un grand
écrivain
m il ya une définition de la littérature
que j'aime bien c'est du chagrin corrigé
par l'orthographe ouais ouais un peu ça
si ça doit être un peu comme quand on
écrit les chansons non je crains qu'on
essaie par l'alcool
votre problème
fondamentalement en fait vous dites je
ne serai jamais l'homme d'un seul livre
ce que ce qui me faisait envie c'est
vous savez ce grand écrivain qui
attachent leur nom à un livre au maire
avec il y adeux montaigne accusé ses
servantes un sac don quichotte ou proust
avec la recherche du temps perdu
allons-y voilà ça ça ça représente
quelque chose alors les femmes ont une
grande importance dans votre vie mais
dans vos livia pas de sexe d'ailleurs je
trouve que c'est une facilité pour
écrire bons livres érotiques
il faut beaucoup de talent le conte du
raid d'aragon ouais c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre mais perd un set aragon
alors écrire des pages pour attirer le
lecteur ça ça me paraît un peu médiocre
voilà alors gens vous êtes de l'académie
française notre ami a commencé dans la
vie en postulant pour la star academy
c'est le jour idéal pour un academy quiz
[Musique]
il faut supporter nico chaque semaine
cette académie star academy il faut
supporter giscard chaque semaine or je
le supporte très bien mais
c'est vrai il s'entendait bien avec lui
en tout cas c'est un excellente
académiciens il vient à l'académie
probablement plus souvent jours ouais
alors il ya une vieille très mal peigné
academy à khénifra demi française à
l'académie française jean n'a pas non et
bien peignés carrère d'encausse
mais la star academy oui il ya une
vieille très mal peigné ils demandent
toutes les journées à ça alors la qualif
ans
je ne dis pas ça par mes dix ans par
time il ya une histoire célèbres ou à un
moment donné le directeur que président
il dit si ces messieurs qui bavardent
faisaient comme ces messieurs qui
dorment ça ces messieurs qui écoutent
pourrez entendre ces messieurs qui
parlera souvient elle
ces classes l'académie française
quand on sort tu es mort l'académie
française où la star academy dès 2002
bravo
[Applaudissements]
laurent fabius on est fan
et le non
dit qui l'adoré la star academy un jour
où il voulait faire jeunes dans une
interview celle interne musée qui
mangeaient les carottes râpées emile
zola ne l'a jamais fait
je crois qu'il s'est présenté 18 h dans
la cour ils n'ont pas pris et la star ac
non plus
jean loup dabadie nakhal at-il fait les
deux les deux bravo
qu'il a fait la star academy avec les
chansons de julien clerc et l'académie
française je voulais rentrer dans
l'avion si vous donnez des noms de gens
qui l'ont fait aucune des deux mais
ça fait partie du patrimoine français
les deux les deux bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu